le résultat pas vraiment de suspense
pour ce premier conseil municipal de la
nouvelle majorité
malgré la candidature surprise de
l'écologiste florence laurie c'est bien
creissan maroci et élu nouveau maire
d'auxerre après vingt ans à gauche la
ville repasse donc officiellement à
droite on va essayer de construire
quelque chose avec l'opposition et
quelque chose d'ambitieux quelque chose
d'audacieux quelque chose de dynamique
pour auxerre en mettant notre petite
touche j'espère vous avez ressenti qui
est très très très collective très
humaine la surprise elle était plutôt du
côté de l'opposition différé elle était
le grand absent de cette assemblée
officiellement toujours conseiller
municipal
l'ancien maire a confié à la presse
vouloir mettre fin à sa vie politique
l'opposition devra donc se trouver un
nouveau leader
je pense une différence comme d'autres
maire considère qu'à partir du moment où
il est battu et à partir du moment où il
a atteint un certain âge il est temps de
prendre sa retraite politique
généralement les mères au bout d'un
moment s'ils sont battus ne siège pas
dans l'ensemble je crois qu'il a pris
une sage décision il a compris qu'on
arrive à la fin d'un cycle et politiques
et donc il a souhaité ne pas venir est
passé directement la main à ceux qui
assureront la suite différait absents il
n'y a donc pas eu de passage de témoin
entre l'ancien maire et le nouveau
cresson marot le regrette mais n'en veut
pas à son prédécesseur
j'ai peut-être pas été suffisamment
convaincant pour l'inciter
éventuellement à envisager une passation
de pouvoir
je pense que quelque part il faut pas
non plus si on sent pas capable de le
faire ou si on se sent pas à l'aise pour
le faire c'est pas la peine double ige
les gens à le faire c'est donc sans
transition que la ville d'auxerre passe
à droite
premier défi pour la nouvelle majorité
la sortie de crise et la reprise
économique